[Musique]
c'est la seule liste qui associe devront
aussi prégnante les citoyens à la
représentation citoyenne française
et puis là il s'appelle envie de robes
écologique et sociale ce qui montre bien
que la question de l'enjeu européen est
présent dans les fondamentaux de notre
vision est ensuite que la question de
l'écologie et le social sont
indissociables du projet comportements
[Musique]
n'ont absolument pas le ps a depuis le
début avec la sq unique et nouvelle
donne
appelé au rassemblement de la gauche
aujourd'hui les radicaux de gauche qui
va rejoindre et le contenu
programmatique est terminée puisque
l'avion et commune sur cet enjeu là d'un
équilibre entre eux la notion d'économie
d'écologie et de social non je pense que
c'est un moment historique pour le parti
socialiste français comme il a été en
comme il a été en 1929 et 69 en
particulier et que aujourd'hui c'est une
question de renaissance avec un jeu de
remettre au coeur du débat politique les
valeurs du socialisme celle de l'égalité
celle de la frontière était bien sûr
mais également de l'équité de la justice
sociale de la redistribution et de la
régulation
p
[Musique]